bonjour marc gaudreault c'est anne-marie
oui oui oui c'est votre fête c'est vous
qui le faites un cadeau de venir vous
voir de vous découvrez or ce que je peux
donner des bisous des baisers bonjour
bonne fin bonjour vous êtes la petite
soeur janet est les gens sont à bout et
les ja dad
oui c'est une bonne journée pour vous
oui
pourriez-vous rendu ce que vous je vous
appelle le phénomène
ah oui pourquoi je suis crois que les
choix comme d'hab ça vous avez à faire
toutes sortes de noms ou j'ai abordé que
tous les sujets oui c'est toujours
pareil à taux courants jeanne marie
bigard et oui mais j'aime ça mon travail
je ne veux pas je vais l'aimer encore
plus sacha que vous l'appréciez parce
que c'est vrai que on parle d'histoire
de personnes puis notre métier pour
toujours bien compris mais j'aime mon
métier parce que je sais qu'on parle à
des gens comme vous et je fais pas au
courant que vous êtes belge répondant
question pour tout l'or du monde
ben voyons donc c'est vous et je suis
très très ému ce soit on va vous allez
vous voir à la télé oui la caméra et là
c'est l'autre cadeau qui vient avec ce
monde est là merci beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est moi qui
vous remercie